[Applause]
thank you kanishka for that introduction
you're going to be a fantastic candidate
and I hope an absolutely brilliant MP of
the next general election
it's fantastic to be back here in Wales
in North Wales where the sun always
shines
we came down from Glasgow yesterday the
predictions were storms snow everywhere
and it's beautiful sunshine all the way
in to clandidno and it's been Sunshine
last night and sunshine again this
morning the sun always shines here on
this conference
although last year you seem to you may
remember I think at this stage it was
driving rain horizontal out there so
let's celebrate the fact that today we
have the sunshine and I have always felt
that a proper Party Conference should
always be near the sea because that
stiff Sea Breeze is invigorating for all
those compositing meetings that we're
busy at
and on a day like this there really is
nothing quite like a walk along the
beach to clear the mind
although in the labor leaders handbook
that I've got
it does say in Big Red Letters
be careful of the sea
and come from come from speaking of Neil
can you believe it can you believe it
it's now 40 years since he was elected
leader of our party
40 years
which means it's 40 years since he went
to Bridgend and gave a speech which
Echoes through the years to speak I
think directly to the country before us
today remember that speech
when he said
I warn you not to be ordinary I warn you
not to be young I warn you not to be ill
I warn you not to be old
conference you won't find a better way
to describe the pernicious effect of the
last 13 years the Neil's words
[Applause]
the anxiety that's gripped our
communities as we Lurch from crisis to
crisis gnawing away at our sense of hope
our belief in a better future
don't forget what this feels like
don't forget how the tour is meted out
the pain to Wales over 13 years
don't forget Neil's words
because conference
we're going to need them on the road
ahead
no complacency
we've got to work for every vote
use the determination those words can
Inspire to build a better Britain a fair
agreena more Dynamic country where
working people succeed aspiration is
rewarded and where together we unlock
the pride and purpose in every community
[Applause]
conference that's the spirit of
devolution the foundation for everything
you've achieved here in the last two
decades
it's time to use that to transform
Britain
give the communities and great nations
of this country the powers they need to
control their destiny
now here in Wales it's fair to say you
know the difference labor can make
better than other parts of Britain
you don't stay the largest party in our
nation for over a century without doing
a lot right
and under Mark and Carolyn's outstanding
leadership still producing record
results in the Senate don't forget that
either
[Applause]
and Mark on behalf of the whole labor
party I want to say how grateful we are
for your dignified service to our party
and to Wales and how pleased we are to
see you here this weekend
[Applause]
there are lessons there are lessons
marked for my labor party for the whole
labor party from your success here in
Wales your clear love for the Welsh
Nation the Embrace of a distinctively
Welsh cultural vision
the collective patriotism of public
service and the pride that comes with
that
never in Mark's words
taking the Welsh public for granted
these are all qualities of Welsh labor
that have guided me in the changes we've
made to the wider party
don't underestimate how important those
changes are
we had to make our labor party fit to
serve our country
[Applause]
conference
that's why we had to show our support
for NATO is non-negotiable understand
the importance of sound money and
anti-Semitism out by its roots country
first party second
[Applause]
but also don't underestimate how
important your qualities are for
renewing the bonds of a labor Britain
nobody should pretend that the case
against Britain as against our Union is
as advanced here as it is in Scotland
but nor should we ignore the fact that
it does find a voice in this nation as
well
and yes those qualities your qualities
help keep it at Bay
but to defeat it comprehensively we need
something else
we need hope
not a grandiose utopian dream kind of
hope I don't mean that
I mean the basic ordinary hope
that we used to take for granted
the sort of hope you can build your
future around that aspirations are made
of
that was shared by working people across
the United Kingdom in good times and bad
and which reached through the
generations to say Britain will be
better for your children
now I worry
that people right across the United
Kingdom don't believe that anymore
that's the deeper cost of Tory rule
a growing sense that hard work isn't
rewarded
that you aren't guaranteed a fair chance
in Britain
that the bonds that tie us together
Community to community across our home
Nations
have been allowed to unravel
conference this is what drives me it's
what my five missions for a better
Britain are all about we've got to get
our sense of hope and possibility back
[Applause]
these are not just words for me
it's the Story of My Life
the journey I've been on from a
working-class family to head of the
crown prosecution service
but it's also the story of our Union
because the case for the union rests has
always rested on the solidarity of
working people pushing Britain forward
in search of that ordinary hope
but when families worry like this about
their children's future
when hard work no longer guarantees Fair
reward or even that your contribution is
respected
and yes
that case becomes harder to make
conference that's what we're fighting
for across our country
we need to meet the forces of division
with renewed hope
that's what our five National missions
are all about
I will never accept that this country is
destined for decline that our best days
belong to the Past
success is all around us it just needs
Direction
people have huge ambition for their
community
they just need it matched
I do believe there's a yearning to come
together to be part of something bigger
and in patience for change for National
renewal and yes as they've done
throughout our history the British
people are turning to labor to provide
it
[Applause]
five National missions
to secure the higher sustained growth in
the G7
make Britain a clean energy superpower
build an NHS fit for the future make our
street safe
and break down the barriers to
opportunity at every stage for every
child
five missions that will Define the
ambition of the next Labor government
five missions that we rekindle that
Shared Hope in every corner of the UK
five missions that raise our sights and
free us from Tory Poverty of ambition
and it does all come back to ambition
when I say we'll get the highest
sustained growth in the G7
or that Britain will have zero carbon
electricity by 2030. that should invite
a sharp intake of breath
and I make no apologies for that
take our clean energy Target
I'm already talking to CEOs to investors
entrepreneurs unions energy workers
about how we get this done
and yes the conversation does start with
a shake of the head
this is a bit much Clear clean energy by
2030 as going some
but we do need leadership with ambition
do need hunger to take on the big
challenges belief in the possibilities
of the future
so
when I say back to them
here's the ambition
here's the plan and here's the
opportunity for you
trust me there is a powerful urgency to
make it happen
a new determination and that's what
mission-led government is all about
[Applause]
but conference the change we offer must
also be credible
working people have had enough of false
promises for a lifetime
and that means the politics of restoring
hope will be hard
I mean honestly where do you begin
the damage they've done the pain they've
inflicted to our economy and public
finances to our reputation around the
world to our NHS and public services
it's immense
you know when Mark said words not too
different to that last October
that display of righteous emotion in the
Senate he didn't just speak for Wales he
spoke for Britain
[Applause]
and the Tories aren't capable of the
change that Britain needs the Tories
aren't capable of delivering a better
future for Wales they made the mess
and as for the cynicism of what they'll
do what the general election
to try and claim political credit for
the sacrifices working people are making
now
we've got to rise above that
spend each day earning the trust of our
communities
meet their attacks with hope
to the people of Wales we must show that
our pride and purpose has not lost any
vigor
that there will be a clear choice at the
next general election
between more Decline and division with
the Taurus or credible change with labor
change for Britain that brings with it
change for Wales and for your community
back to the British people everywhere we
must show how this Spirit combines with
the solidarity we offer across the
United Kingdom
how together
we can deliver something even more
precious
a Britain once again on the front foot
with a sense of hope of possibility of
ambition a Britain that gets its future
back
[Applause]
so imagine just for a moment
what that might look like conference
imagine the better whales we would see
after 10 years of national renewal labor
governments in Westminster and Cardiff
what does it look like
I'll tell you
our economy is stable
growth is high and sustained across the
country and here in Wales north and
south
businesses have the certainty to invest
the NHS is back in good health
crime is down
there's more opportunity more affordable
housing better paid jobs
families feel they can get old again
look forward with hope again
we're leading the world on climate
change
people from across the globe come to
Marvel at the floating offshore wind
farms of the Celtic Sea
bills are cheaper homes are warmer and
well insulated
cutting-edge science and world-class
services are driving economic growth new
jobs Industries Technologies emerge that
benefit every part of Wales
[Applause]
and there's a thriving green steel
sector that stretches from canelli
through to Port Talbot and up to Newport
a cyber cluster on the North Wales Coast
as well as in the south
some of the most vital semiconductor
components in the world
still made here
tourism booming Welsh agriculture going
from strength to strength
working people are respected as the
wealth creators that drive Britain
forward
and rexham Hollywood wrexham
not quite in the Champions League but
not far off
[Applause]
conference seriously there's no reason
why we can't reach for this
a fairer Greener whales in a fairer
Greener labor Britain
it can be ours but it requires a new way
of doing politics a total overhaul of
the Westminster system
we have an economy that Hoards potential
and a politics that Hoards power
no similar country puts so much decision
making in the hands of so few people and
that leads to more inequality across our
country than anywhere else in Europe
that's not a coincidence
I'm utterly convinced by this economic
reform and political change must go hand
in hand
pick any of Britain's current problems
energy security productivity immigration
to be here all day
but it wouldn't matter
the pattern is always the same
distracted by the short-term obsessions
that fixate Westminster
blinker to the possibility of an active
government that sets the direction
we lurch
from crisis to crisis always react
always behind the curve
a sticking plaster never a cure
now
sticking plaster politics
that's why every crisis hits Britain
harder than our competitors
the only country in the G7 still poorer
than before the pandemic
and the harm that does to the prospect
of bringing Britain together
that's vast
so we've got to take it on
only labor will fix this only labor will
unlock the pride and purpose of all our
communities
only labor will devolve economic power
and control out of Westminster
[Applause]
the argument is simple
the decisions which create wealth in our
communities should be taken by people
with skin in the game
now
take the Scandal
of what's happened here in Wales
with what used to be EU structural funds
the shared Prosperity fund
funds that have been essential for Welsh
businesses and communities for years
powers that have been exercised here
since the Inception of devolution
the Tories have used the brexit process
to Take Back Control of that money not
from the EU but from Wales it's an
outrage
the Welsh government used those funds to
get unemployment down for wage subsidies
redundancy support investment in the
green opportunities of the future the
UK's first Regional Bank supporting your
world-class universities modernizing the
Welsh economy
now
they have to watch the tourists sit on
their hands as a global supply chain
crisis hits key Welsh industries from
steel to semiconductors
well no more because today I can
announce that the next Labor government
will return power over its economic
Destiny to Wales
[Applause]
the decision the decision-making role
for the Walsh government on structural
funds will be restored it's time for
Wales to Take Back Control
that's the change Wales and Britain
needs change which comes from Unlocking
The Pride and purpose of communities
everywhere which spreads power and
opportunity out of Westminster and puts
people in control an end sticking
plaster politics
a new approach to politics and democracy
everywhere in Britain built on a new
approach to growth and our economy
because conference
you can't overstate the importance of
economic growth
it's the oxygen for our Ambitions the
lifeblood of a strong society and a
dynamic economy
but look
I say again
this will be hard
the lesson of the last year is Stark
lose control of the economy and its
businesses and working people who pick
up the bill we can't let that happen
even when it puts a break on things we
might like to do in power
sound money in our public finances must
come first
constraints must be accepted
institutions respected a rock of
economic stability
our mission for growth must be built on
that
but alongside it we must still be bold
on reform on reconstruction or national
renewal that's what people expect from a
labor government and we will deliver it
[Applause]
so we will give working people growth
from the Grassroots with good jobs
productivity growth in every part of the
country growth which makes everyone not
just a few better off
will get us moving forward on science
technology and innovation
with a more powerful British bank that
can help scale businesses new and old
and a modern industrial strategy which
gets everyone around the table and
removes barriers to investment
we'll create jobs that are well paid and
secure and in the Tory era of low pay
with our new deal for working people
[Applause]
and will reform procurement to nurture
more resilient Supply chains project a
more open stance in the world
and yes fix the broken brexit deal that
is a vital part of raising our Ambitions
on growth
[Applause]
and Conference so is tackling climate
change head-on
I come to this not just as leader of the
UK labor party
but as a dad
and I said Dad
I'm spurred on by the voices of our
children
The Cry of indignation demanding Our
Generation act before it's too late
it's a matter of Justice
about the fairness and better society
that I came into politics to create
but also the biggest opportunity we've
had in decades to make this country work
for working people
conference this is why we need a
collective sense of mission across our
home Nations
we've got to come together and write a
new chapter in our national story about
how our generation tackled the climate
emergency and used it to create the jobs
the industries the opportunities of the
future
that's what our green Prosperity plan is
all about
turning the UK into a green growth
superpower with investment in Wind solar
nuclear hydrogen green steel and carbon
capture insulation for 19 million homes
and GB energy a new company that will
take advantage of the opportunities in
clean British power and turn them into
good secure well-paid jobs
and yes conference because it's right
for jobs because it will help us tackle
climate change GB energy will be
publicly owned
[Applause]
and let's be crystal clear about the
benefits which will flow to the Welsh
people from this plant
let's show how Welsh businesses and
families will get cheaper bills forever
how Wales can get real energy
independence from tyrants like Putin
forever
how we can give every community
from Anglesey to aberdare a fair shot at
the jobs and prosperity of the future
conference
for 13 years you've been the bulwark
against tourists here in Wales
the same length of time as the last
Labor government spent in power
and what have they got to show for it
what's the list of achievements they can
rattle off
the Legacy for our country that they can
be proud of
where is their minimum wage their
equality act they're slashing of child
poverty rates the Regeneration of our
cities the rebuilding of our public
Remain the investment in culture sport
technology infrastructure education the
Devolution of power and control to the
nation where is it
Britney's change
people know that
the people of Wales know Britain needs
change for them
they know our economy needs to work
better for working people
that our Public Services need to be
fixed that the emergency of climate
change needs bold action
and that our political system needs a
total overhaul with communities finally
in the driving seat
we must say to them
none of this can be achieved through
more division
but if you place your faith in labor
this is the change we offer to Wales and
Britain the case for a New Britain where
communities control their own destiny
climate change is defeated growth
supercharged politics a force for Unity
and good
a whales that is proud confident
ambitious and successful thriving in a
better Britain a Britain with its hope
and future back a Britain with a new
sense of mission thank you conference
okay
[Applause]